de quoi va-t-on parler aujourd'hui j'ai
deux choses très intéressantes
vous profitez en mais monsieur grenat
pas caler sa caméra correctement voilà
comme ça il y aura pas de fous on est
toujours au début des années 2020 c'est
l'heure un peu de se poser la question
des smartphones qui vont arriver cette
année alors je vous ai déjà parlé des
smartphones de samsung je vous ai déjà
parlé du p 42 war with déjà parlé de pas
mal de choses et justement aujourd'hui
on va parler d'apple parce que apple
c'est vraiment une marque est très
attendu on attend beaucoup les nouveaux
iphone qui sont des références dans leur
domaine mais justement aujourd'hui je
vais pas vous parler du futur ou des
futurs iphone qui seront présentés pour
mois de septembre 2020 non je vous
parlais des iphone qui pourrait arriver
potentiellement très rapidement au mois
de mars pensent que oui on l'attend
depuis très longtemps
oui il ya des rumeurs depuis très
longtemps sur un iphone est ce 2è ce
nouvelle génération s eux qu'on attend
depuis longtemps
j'en ai déjà parlé il ya un bon moment
de cet iphone et ce2 quid de l'iphone
se2 et notre grand produit qu'on attend
c'est l'iphone s2 apple pourrait sortir
en 2018 une nouvelle version de son
iphone est ce c'est à dire un design
vraiment comme l'iphone disent un grand
écran une petite encoche sur le haut par
contre pas de recharge à induction avec
la caméra trou d'air et fayçal dit une
seule caméra à l'arrière pas de te child
dit forcément une structure en aluminium
une batterie un peu plus anciennes pas
les battrions elle met les batteries
rectangulaire avec des capacités qui
sont inférieurs 3 giga de ram
voilà un peu ce que dit cette rumeur
puisqu'il est attendu attendu attendu
puis régulièrement des petites piqûres
de rappel avec des rumeurs qui ressort
qui ressurgissent qui nous font penser
que cet iphone s2 pourrait
potentiellement arriver alors pourquoi
est-ce que cet iphone et ce2 et tant
attendu tout simplement parce que déjà
quand l'iphone est sorti il ya quelques
années c'était l'un des iphone les moins
chères c'est toujours actuellement
l'iphone moins cher lors sa sortie et
puis surtout c'était vraiment
intéressant c'était son format ont été
surtout petit format smartphone parce
qu'aujourd'hui les smartphones sont de
plus en plus grands nos poches ne
grandissent pas nos sacs n'agrandit spa
mais par contre les smartphones e
agrandissent alors point positif c'est
qu'effectivement on a je dirais une
meilleure expérience multimédia d'avoir
un écran beaucoup plus grand
mais pour ceux et celles qui ne
s'intéressent pas réellement à
l'expérience multimédia qui veulent un
smartphone un peu plus compact qui tient
facilement dans la poche avec un petit
écran et bien l'iphone est ce est un
excellent produit mais mal
et où il ya quelques années donc d'où
l'idée d'où l'intérêt de voir arriver un
des fans et ceux de leur iphone et ce
autour c'est pas s'il va s'appeler
iphone et ce2 ou s'il va s'appeler
l'iphone 9
il ya deux écoles de rumeurs différentes
infections et d'un côté l'iphone se2
parce que c'est l'iphone et ce numéro 2
ça vous aura pas échappé
c'est une mise à jour de la gamme ça
paraît assez logique et d'un autre côté
l'iphone 9 pistes et lui l'iphone 8 il
ressemblerait un peu à l'iphone 8
on n'est pas dans la gamme iphone disent
je ne crois pas du tout à la rumeur du
nom iphone pas un instant pourquoi tout
simplement parce que il ya une
numérotation qui a évolué avec apple
vous avez suivi 26 iphone c'est tania
les déclinaisons les si les essais et
compagnie on connaît l'histoire iphone 8
et ensuite on est passé directement à
l'iphone disent pourquoi parce que ça
marquer les 10 ans de l'iphone et de
numéro 9 a été oubliée du coup on dire
est que cette boîte iphone 9 non je
crois pas un instant il iphone d10s
iphone 11
vous croyez qu apple sur un autre format
me sentir à un iphone 9 ça voudrait dire
qu'on reviendrait en arrière ça veut
dire qu'il ya un numéro oublié on va
venir ajouter un élément manquant dans
le puzzle on est en 2020 en 2000 devant
pourra voir arriver soit un iphone 11
aces soit un iphone 12
pourquoi est-ce qu'on imaginerait la
même année voir un iphone 9 un iphone 12
aux défauts dont 11 aces
il ya un truc qui coïnciderait pas
d'autant plus que ce produit très
rarement une mise à jour de l'iphone est
ce une dénomination qui a marché qui
serait un vent non commercial qui
donnerait une image positive plutôt
qu'une image négatif avec une
numérotation qui daterait d'il ya
quelques années donc clairement le nom
iphone 9
j'y crois pas pour les donc sans les
folles s2 je valide
quand est il pourrait sortir ça c'est
aussi un pas très important lors sont
des rumeurs bien évidemment mais selon
bloomberg il pourrait être présenté en
mars 2020 et il pourrait y avoir toute
la phase d'industrialisation la phase de
fabrication qui débuterait au mois de
février 2020 un smartphone bien
évidemment format réduit mais avec un
prix aussi réduit il serait disponible à
moins de 500 dollars
si on regarde ce qui pourrait arriver en
euros bien évidemment 500 $ je vous
rajoute la tecié ça vous transforme et
ou 100 euros
on serait à mon avis à un peu moins de
600 euros pour être sur un smartphone
qui oscillerait entre 500 à 600 euros ce
qui sera globalement des iphones les
moins chers note assortie connaissant à
peu les connaissons le cahier des
charges et la qualité de fabrication de
l'apple on pourra voir un smartphone
moins cher notre et y aurait pas une
baisse en terme de qualité aurait des
choix qui serait effectivement fait on
pourrait pas tout avoir
la néanmoins qualitativement en aura un
produit qui serait bien fini et de bonne
facture il ya aussi la deux écoles qui
s'affrontent on a une première école qui
garderait un design identique un petit
peu ce qu'on avec l'iphone 8 c'est à
dire un smartphone avec des grandes bord
durant aux grandes bordure en bas ici
pas dans kof
ici pas de faille saïdi et on pourra
voir le grand retour en force de tochigi
pour venir déverrouiller facilement sans
smartphone ça c'est la première version
il ya une autre école qui vous dit ok on
n'aurait pas du tout ça ça on prend aux
tchèques la deuxième idée qui nous dit
effectivement qu'on aura un smartphone
avec une encoche on aurait non pas ces
grandes bord noires en haut et en bas on
retrouverait la même idée que ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui avec un iphone
11 on se pro un iphone 10 un iphone et
compagnie c'est à dire une encoche des
petites border tous les côtés et surtout
un meilleur ratio écran châssis c'est un
petit peu la deuxième idée comprendre ce
côté là bien évidemment vous n'auriez
pas de tschaï dit vous auriez fait saïdi
pour déverrouiller très facilement et
façon complètement sécurisé une fois de
plus les rumeurs fanta soit d'un écran
de 4,7 pouces soit d'un écran de 5,4
pouces une dalle ips lcd retina ça reste
un petit peu flou on sait pas exactement
quel design aura ce smartphone
quelles technologies l'aura pour
déverrouiller mais on devine un petit
peu les coteaux j'aurai un peu de mal à
croire effectivement que apple nous sort
un design datant de l'iphone 8
une fois de plus ça me semblerait pour
revenir un peu en arrière par rapport à
toute la stratégie d'apple apple
généralement va pas à l'économiser ok on
va sortir un nouveau smartphone dont on
rêve dans les dernières technologies
bras pour faire des ajustements
budgétaires comme le smartphone coup
quand même relativement moins cher mais
j'aurais du mal à croire qu'apple
aujourd'hui à il nous sortir un
smartphone un petit peu old school avec
un coach heidi en termes d'image de
marque on dit serait pas je crois
davantage à des news apporte un
smartphone avec un faith heidi avec un
grand écran avec en poche un lcd
ça paraît très clairement beaucoup plus
haut gît un écran qui serait fournie par
lg je sais pas si vous le savez au
niveau des fabricants de dalles pour les
smartphones y en a deux grands qui
ressortent c'est samsung
d'un côté qui est vraiment je dirais le
compétiteur le challenger le concurrent
numéro un d'apple samsung nos côtés et
le deuxième à côté 2e pouces clg pour
l'instant apple se fournirait chez sg et
non pas chez samsung avec les écrans
samsung display alors le dos du
smartphone il ressemblerait quasiment à
ce qu'on retrouve au niveau de l'iphone
10 r c'est à dire un seul capteur photo
on serait sensiblement dans la même idée
on gardera
par contre le capteur principal que vous
avez sur les iphone 11
un capteur de 12 mégapixels qui marchent
merveilleusement bien
une fois de plus je vous le dit apple ne
va pas l'économie ils vont effectivement
pas mettre de tels objectifs en
fectivement pad ultra-grand-angle on
peut pas non plus tout avoir un prix
relativement bas par rapport aux
produits d'apple
néanmoins c'est important qu'on veut
sortir un smartphone avec une caméra de
mauvaise qualité
ça leur ressemblent aurait absolument
pas très smart phones qui aurait la
dernière puce en date d'apple la puce
attrait ce qu'on peut retrouver dans les
iphones 11 en or et 3 giga de ram soit
64 giga de stockage sous moi 128 giga de
stockage et connaissant apple tout ça
bien évidemment non extensible mais vous
aurez à claude pour aller tous stockés
derrière facilement on aurait bien
évidemment la toute dernière version
d'ios la charge se ferait soin de votre
câble l'ethnie que vous viendrez
brancher dessus soit directement avec de
la charge sans fil qui dit charge sans
fil didot anvers voilà un peu pour le
grand portrait robot qu'on peut décider
aujourd'hui autour de ce smartphone
qu'est-ce que ça vraiment intéressant
mais j'ai quand même certaines réserves
tout simplement parce qu'en règle
générale lorsqu'on voit les rumeurs se
décider je prends par exemple les
rumeurs des samsung galaxy s 20 toutes
les rumeurs tous les rangs du tout ce
que vous voyez en ligne toutes les
fuites vous avez exactement toujours
quasiment le même rendu au niveau du
module photo haut niveau l'écran pour
trouver vraiment le produit toutes les
rumeurs viennent un petit peu se
compléter pour vous définir réellement
un produit là il ya quand même pas mal
de rumeurs différent que ce soit au
niveau de la taille de l'écran au niveau
de l'écran lui-même le fait d'avoir un
taux de change il fait d'avoir un pay
side il fait d'avoir un coach pas
d'encoches là on a plus l'impression
qu'ils sont des personnes qui viennent
donner leur avis personnel mais qu'on
n'a pas réellement de grosses rumeurs de
grosses fuites en tout cas qu'ils des
tâches néanmoins ce qui me permet de
croire un petit peu effectivement à la
véracité de l'arrivée de ce produit
c'est les infos qu'ils viennent de
bloomberg qui me paraît une source très
fiable donc j'ai bon espoir et je garde
vraiment exporte le smartphone avec
parce que ce serait extrêmement
intéressant à vous de me dire maintenant
en bas en commentaire ce que vous en
pensez
est ce que vous croyez vraiment que cet
iphone s2 fun neuf pourrait arriver
cette année et si oui est ce que vous
pourriez être tenté est ce que vous
pourriez acheter surtout qu'est-ce que
vous viendriez retrouver dans ce type au
logis smartphone est ce que ce petit
format vous tenterez est ce que vous
pourriez faire un petit peu l'impasse ce
côté multimédia alors on pourrait
regarder des films des séries ont nourri
de la performance desriac la puce à 13
me battrai absolument pas là dessus mais
plus petit écran moins de confort en
visionnage on peut pas tout avoir
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire paradis pour tous dès
demain pourquoi est ce qu'on continue à
parler et à calais vous avez de l'amour
du lobe à des matches à eau
[Musique]